[Musique]
pour faire connaître les dispositifs en
faveur de l'insertion mis en place par
le département des séquences
d'information et de sensibilisation des
chefs d'entreprise sont organisées dans
les quatre coins de l'île depuis le
début de l'année ce mercredi 29 juin
c'est à s'entendre et au siège de l'urma
de la chambre des métiers et de
l'artisanat que s'est tenu un séminaire
visant à présenter le dispositif est
plus ainsi que le contrat pec marchand
l'objectif c'est d'échanger avec les
employeurs et de les inciter à rentrer
dans le cadre de ce dispositif de la
expliqué la simplicité du dispositif de
la variable expliquer l'intérêt pour les
bénéficiaires du rsa qui auront une
amélioration de leur pouvoir d'achat
parce que je le rappelle grâce aux airs
plus eh bien on maintient les droits
sociaux des bénéficiaires du rsa qui
veulent travailler les chefs
d'entreprise ont peut-être des crêtes à
sage est compliqué pour bénéficier du a
plus est ce que ces démarches à faire
quelles sont elles alors qu'il suffit
d'appeler un numéro unique et ça permet
aux employeurs d'avoir de nouvelles
forces vives de nouvelles personnes qui
ont des capacités pour travailler dans
l'entreprise et on peut coupler le pecq
marchand qui sauront ce sont donc des
emplois financés donc la charge et moins
de pros chefs d'entreprise et le r plus
ce qui permettra aux bénéficiaires du
pack marchande avoir plus d'avoir plus
puisqu'ils bénéficient du pecq plus le
est plus donc d'avoir un revenu
supérieur et qui permettra aux chefs
d'entreprise d'avoir un emploi qui
financent et donc la charge est moindre
pour lui donc sur couple le pack
marchand et le et plus c'est tout bénef
pour l'employeur comme pour l'employé
nombreux sont les acteurs économiques de
l'est à avoir fait le déplacement pour
en savoir plus sur ce dispositif on a
besoin beaucoup de la main d'oeuvre
qualifiée donc ses nuances au coup de
pouce pour pouvoir motiver ces jeunes
aller se former pourquoi pas plutôt si
futur est député et chef d'entreprise et
le coût de la vie simplement le monte
avec le co vide et que cet accident dont
il pense que l'initiative de conseillers
pas le mental c'est un bon plus comme à
chaque séminaire des projets de
partenariat entre des entreprises
présentes et le département se sont
concrétisées à l'issue de cette séquence
cela permettra aux conseillers
d'insertion air plus de pouvoir orienter
les candidatures en fonction des besoins
des employeurs
[Musique]